anyway here to break this all down for
us Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett
along with the editor-in-chief
investigative reporter just thenews.com
John Solomon and former acting attorney
general Matt Whitaker is with us thank
you all
right let's we now have the FD 1023 form
John Solomon and you have written
extensively on this and we have a
trusted FBI informant they paid him
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
past hired a hunter is hired by barisma
to use his father to help protect this
company from the investigation that was
ongoing they even though they thought he
was dumb and stupid and dumb as a dog
their words so uh what really went on
here
well listen when this document comes in
it's no different than when the Steele
dossier first came into the FBI in 2017
it's known as unverified intelligence
from a reliable source be up until the
time Christopher Steele gave the crap on
uh Donald Trump he had been reliable we
later learned that was a bad piece of
information in this case the FBI started
to look into it let me tell you what
they found the first thing you do is is
there any evidence that money change
hands to the Biden family yes they found
millions of dollars flowing to Hunter
Biden at a pace that would be consistent
with a five million dollar payment
secondly they started to look was Joe
Biden ever referred to in any other
documents I had as the big guy yes they
found that in the China deal they
started to look did Dr Biden ever say
that his father did something for
barisma yes they found him in documents
that they had in their possession going
back to 2016 they had begun
corroborating this informants
information it moves from uncorroborate
unverified to a point where it justifies
a investigation at that point the FBI
stood down on the evidence on this in
the 2020 election occurred this has not
been thoroughly investigated but what we
do know there's a significant trail of
evidence that actually verifies the
things that this informant did you're
going to get to see some of that over
the next weeks one of the questions that
has always stood out did Joe Biden ever
meet with Barista officials I think next
week we're going to get that answer okay
let's go over the top 10 findings that
you put up on your website let me ask
Matt Whitaker about let's go over some
of them anyway
and Barista Holdings hired Hunter to
have his father protect the company that
has been revealed Barista a feared
chokin's probe would stop its efforts to
get publicly traded in the U.S so there
was a lot of money on the line uh
barisma knew that Hunter Biden had no
experience they thought he was Dumb and
they they sought additional counsel the
CHS believed the payments made to the
bidens illicit
in nature Barista Executives you know
anyway it's not happening anyway we'll
put it up on the screen in a minute but
you know there are so many allegations
here I'm trying to understand Matt how
is it the FBI had all this information
for a long period of time and didn't act
on any of it how is it they allowed the
statute of limitations to pass how is it
that that agents IRS whistleblower
agents had to come out and tell us the
truth and risk their life and career and
an FBI agent had to do the same how come
it took them to expose this truth well
Sean you know based on everything we now
know it's very clear to me that the FBI
lacked an interest and a curiosity in
actually pursuing these criminal
investigations both against Hunter Biden
and against Joe Biden and the question
is why and who decided that there was no
curiosity or desire to investigate these
to the fullest extent of the law and you
know this shoken firing has always
troubled me because of the he was
investigating barisma for criminal acts
Joe Biden leverages a billion dollars of
United States taxpayers dollars to get
him fired and the investigation against
barisma who Hunter Biden is very closely
associated with goes away I mean that in
and of itself should make the FBI want
to get to the bottom of this and run it
to ground but as John describes they
just decided not to and I think that is
that's beyond malpractice when it comes
to criminal investigations all right let
me go over this with you Greg chair and
let's talk about the legal aspects so
Barista hires Hunter to have his father
protect the company Maurice Smith feared
that the prosecutor's probe would stop
the efforts to get publicly traded in
the U.S that's a lot of money they're
paying a fortune to Hunter they know
Hunter's dumb and has no experience
the CHS believed the payments made to
the bidens were illicit in nature
barisma Executives believed they had
coerced they were coerced into paying
and hiring Hunter
bragged that he had covered his tracks
on the Biden payments the FBI received a
lead involving cryptocurrency the FBI
knew that Joe's Associates called him
the big guy the FBI began receiving
information on the bidens as early as
2017. can you explain what's going on at
the Department of Justice and the FBI
corruption cover-up protection racket
you know we've reported Sean for years
that Joe Biden's Infamous brag in which
he threatened Ukraine into firing the
prosecutor investigating barisma looked
very much like bribery and extortion
because Hunter Biden was on the
company's payroll pocketing Millions for
doing nothing except exerting his
father's influence now whether Joe
received any of the cash payments that's
irrelevant under the law it's a crime to
use your public office as vice president
to confer a benefit on a foreign
government a billion in financial aid in
exchange for something of value to your
family money it's called bribery
conspiracy violation of the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act and take a look at
that term coercion in the 1023 form that
supports extortion but that's not all we
also know that the money paid was
funneled through a complex web of shell
companies well that smacks of money
laundering tax fraud not to mention
racketeering so the question is were the
bidens selling out their country well it
sure looks like it doesn't it remember
bribery and treason are impeachable
offenses in addition to being felonies
so you know this is a blockbuster
Scandal that could Doom Biden's
presidency uh we'll give the last
question to John Solomon next week Devin
Archer the partner of Hunter Biden part
of the family Syndicate is going to be
apparently testifying what can we expect
John Solomon
I think we'll get some data points about
when Joe Biden did intervene to assist
Hunter Biden's comments and I wanted to
point out one thing tonight the White
House is staking their defense tonight
on the 2019 impeachment trial testimony
I encourage everybody to Bone up on that
because next week after many years of
litigation in foia we're going to
release a lot of documents we'll see how
well the impeachment testimony of 2019
and 2020 holds up when people see these
new documents all right John great
reporting Matt great analysis Greg great
legal analysis thank you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else